양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고 교육 분야 기술 총괄이에요.
IBM Quantum에서 일하고 있어요. 이번이 시리즈의 아홉 번째 수업이고, 세 번째 단원의 첫 번째 수업이에요. 세 번째 단원은 양자 정보의 일반적인
공식화에 관한 내용이에요. 지금까지는 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화를 사용해 왔는데요.
그 공식화에서 양자 상태는 유클리드 노름이 1인 복소 벡터로 표현돼요.
이와 대조적으로, 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에서는 양자 상태가
밀도 행렬이라고 하는 특정 유형의 행렬로 표현돼요. 이 단원의 첫 번째 수업은 밀도 행렬에 초점을 맞추고 있어요.
수업이 진행되면서 밀도 행렬이 무엇인지, 어떻게 작동하는지 알아볼 거예요. 밀도 행렬은 정말
유용하고 다양한 장점이 있는데, 그것도 다룰 거예요. 밀도 행렬은 양자 상태 벡터로 표현할 수 있는 것보다
더 넓은 범위의 상태를 표현할 수 있어요. 예를 들어, 노이즈에 영향을 받은 시스템의 상태나 양자 상태의 무작위
선택도 포함할 수 있어요. 또한 Bloch 구도 살펴볼 텐데, qubit 상태를 아주 멋지고
단순하게 기하학적으로 생각할 수 있는 방법을 제공해 줘요. 그리고 그게 밀도 행렬과 어떻게 연결되는지도 볼 거예요.
Pauli 행렬을 통해 꽤 놀라운 방식으로 연결되거든요. 마지막으로 복합 시스템에서의 밀도 행렬을 다룰 거예요.
특히, 다른 시스템과 연관되어 있더라도 고립된 시스템의 양자 상태를 어떻게 설명할 수 있는지 볼 거예요.
다른 시스템과 연관되어 있다는 건 다른 시스템과 얽혀 있을 가능성도 포함해요. 이건 중요한 부분이에요.
그리고 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는 쉽게 할 수 없는 것이기도 해요. 수업의 개요를 말씀드릴게요.
먼저 관련 정의와 몇 가지 예시를 포함한 밀도 행렬의 기초부터 시작할 거예요.
그리고 밀도 행렬이 양자 상태 벡터와 어떻게 연결되는지도 이야기할 거예요. 그 다음에는 밀도 행렬의 볼록 조합, 즉
밀도 행렬의 가중 평균을 취하면 어떻게 되는지 이야기할 거예요. 특정
완전히 혼합된 상태라는 예시부터 시작할 거예요. 고전적인 확률 상태가 밀도 행렬의
특수한 경우로 어떻게 볼 수 있는지도 다룰 거예요. 그리고 선형 대수의 스펙트럼 정리가 이
맥락에서 어떻게 작용하는지도 이야기할 거예요. 수업의 세 번째 부분은 Bloch 구에 관한 것으로,
수업 시작 부분에서 언급했듯이 단일 qubit 상태를 기하학적으로 볼 수 있게 해줘요. 수업의 네 번째 부분에서는 다중
시스템에서 밀도 행렬이 어떻게 작동하는지 이야기할 거예요. 얽힌 상태를 포함한 다양한 종류의 곱 상태와 상관 상태를 논의할 거예요.
그리고 복합 시스템의 고립된 부분의 상태를 밀도 행렬로 설명하는 축소 상태의 개념도 다룰 거예요.
이것은 부분 트레이스라는 연산을 사용해 계산할 수 있어요. 수업의 기술적인 내용으로 들어가기 전에,
밀도 행렬 사용의 동기를 설명하는 데 잠깐 시간을 내는 게 좋을 것 같아요. 단순화된
양자 정보 공식화를 사용하면, 밀도 행렬 없이도 예를 들어
Shor의 인수분해 알고리즘 같은 양자 알고리즘을 어려움 없이 설명할 수 있어요. 그렇다면 왜 굳이 밀도 행렬을
또는 이 일반적인 양자 정보 공식화를 사용해야 할까요? 여러 이유가 있어요. 첫째로, 밀도 행렬은
양자 상태 벡터보다 더 넓은 범위의 양자 상태를 표현할 수 있어요. 불확실성이나
무작위성이 있는 양자 상태도 포함해요. 이건 양자 계산에서 노이즈의 영향을 모델링할 때 중요해요.
둘째로, 밀도 행렬을 사용하면 복합 시스템의 고립된 부분의 양자 상태를 설명할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 다른 시스템과 얽혀 있어서 잠시 무시하고 싶은 시스템의 상태도요. 수업 시작 부분에서 언급했듯이,
이건 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는 쉽거나 자연스럽게 할 수 없는 거예요.
세 번째 이유는, 밀도 행렬을 사용하면 고전적인 정보가 실제로
특수한 경우로 나타난다는 거예요. 한쪽에는 확률적 상태와 연산 사이의 유사성이 있고
다른 한쪽에는 양자 상태 벡터와 유니터리 연산이 있는 것처럼 비유하는 게 아니라, 양자 및 고전적 정보가
단일한 수학적 프레임워크 안에서 함께 설명되는 거예요. 이건 양자 정보의 수학적 연구에 필수적이에요.
그래서 수학적인 수준에서 양자 정보를 진지하게 이해하고 싶다면, 밀도 행렬에 대해 배우는 것을 강력히
권장해요. 이제 밀도 행렬의 정의부터 시작해 볼게요.
정의를 위해, X가 시스템이고 시그마가 그 고전적 상태 집합이라고 가정해요. 그리고
그 용어를 사용할 때 우리의 가정은 시그마가 유한하고 비어 있지 않다는 거예요. 늘 그렇듯이 원하면
다른 이름을 선택할 수도 있어요. 시스템 X의 상태를 설명하는 밀도 행렬은 복소수
원소를 가진 행렬인데, 행과 열이 고전적 상태 집합과 대응되어 있어요. 명확히 말하면
행과 열이 동시에 같은 대응 관계를 가진다는 거예요. 이는 밀도
행렬이 항상 정방 행렬임을 의미해요. 정방 행렬이어야 하는 것 외에도 만족해야 할 몇 가지 조건이 있는데,
곧 다룰 거예요. 사람들은 보통 밀도 행렬을 나타내는 데 특정 소문자 그리스 문자를 사용해요.
로(ρ)가 흔히 첫 번째 선택이고, 다른 일반적인 선택으로는 소문자 시그마와 타우가 있어요. 화면에 나와 있어요.
이건 그냥 관례이지만, 이런 관례들은 보통 유용해요. 더 쉽게 인식할 수 있게 해주거든요.
이제 유효한 밀도 행렬이 되기 위해 충족해야 할 조건 또는 요구사항에 대해 이야기해 볼게요.
조건이 두 가지 있어요. 먼저 그것들을 나열하고
그 다음에 무엇을 의미하는지 더 자세히 설명할게요. 첫 번째 조건은
밀도 행렬이 단위 트레이스, 즉 트레이스가 1이어야 한다는 거예요. 두 번째 조건은
밀도 행렬이 양의 반정치여야 한다는 거예요. 두 경우 모두 화면에 나타난 것처럼 이 두 조건을 간결하게 기호로 표현할 수 있어요.
이제 두 조건을 더 자세히 살펴볼게요.
첫 번째 조건은 트레이스에 관한 것인데, 이건 모든 정방 행렬에 대해 정의된 아주 중요한 함수예요.
단순히 대각 원소들의 합이에요. 그걸 명시적으로 표현하는 방정식이 여기 있어요.
트레이스에 대해 할 말이 꽤 많고 중요한 이유도 있지만, 지금은 아주 기본적인
특성 하나만 살펴볼게요. 바로 선형 함수라는 점이에요. 트레이스의 다른 특성들은 나중에 필요할 때 다룰 거예요.
밀도 행렬에 집중하기 위해 두 번째 요구사항으로 넘어갈게요. 그 요구사항은
밀도 행렬이 양의 반정치여야 한다는 거예요. 이것도 여러 상황에서 나타나는 중요한 개념이에요.